peu
[Musique]
assainir la vie politique du pays
exclure toute probabilité de retour au
passé
organiser la vie publique sans risque de
conflits et de perturbations sociales
restaurer un pouvoir émanant du paf
exercé par le peuple est contrôlé par le
port tels sont les objectifs officiels
de la république de grève ainsi qu'ils
ont été définis par le gouvernement
d'athènes
[Applaudissements]
l'actuel premier ministre monsieur
georges papadopoulos ancien colonel
darty grey sera le slam autorisé à
solliciter le suffrage de ses
concitoyens
il sera donc élu président le 29 juillet
prochain et ce pour sept ans
en effet le gouvernement ne semble guère
inquiet quant à l'issue du scrutin
tout sera fait pour qu'il soit positif s
il ne l'était pas a déclaré le
secrétaire d'état à l'information
un autre référendum sous une forme
différente serait soumis au peuple grec
en agent électoral
monsieur stylianos pattakos vice premier
ministre et chef historique de la
révolution du 21 avril 1967
c'est ainsi qu'on le désigne
officiellement monsieur pattakos donc ne
ménage pas sa peine
la perfidie de l'ancien roi constantin
aujourd'hui déchu et les réalisations du
régime lui fournissent la matière de ses
allocutions ces cancers général de
blindés s'est transformé en chantre de
la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
ici près de salonique au lendemain de
l'abolition de la monarchie deux mois
dernier
[Applaudissements]
dit
en grec democracia signifie à la fois
république et démocratie la république
sera la forme constitutionnelle du
régime reste la démocratie aux dires
mêmes des dirigeants ce sera une
démocratie un peu spécial applicable
réalité grecque
[Applaudissements]
ces réalités le gouvernement cherche à
les rendre aussi attrayante que faire se
peut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et monsieur pat à cause de promettre une
république dont plusieurs générations
avaient la nostalgie de promettre une
graisse nouvelle qui aura pour emblème
le phénix renaissant de ses cendres le
plus sûr garant de cette république
seront donc les militaires même est
précisément le premier souci de monsieur
papadopoulos et d'assurer son ascendant
sur ses frères d'armes de qu'il détient
toute autorité
[Applaudissements]
quant à l'opposition après avoir été
emprisonné déportés exilés elle est
aujourd'hui officiellement inexistante
et muette
les anciens partis politiques sont
toujours interdits leur leader néanmoins
cherche à reconstituer une coalition
contre le régime
nous avons rencontré l'un d'eux at-elle
musique10 ministre de monsieur
papandréou
entre 1963 et 1965 monsieur x 10 6 sorti
de prison il ya quelques mois il est en
quelque sorte le porte parole de cette
opposition illégal ou contre la
monarchie pour les machines la
république c'est un référendum pour que
le peuple eric puisse exprimer enchaîné
son désir pour rester serein sous un
régime de dictature et qu'elle va
d'aller voir demander mais est ce qu'il
existe une personne qui puisse voter
librement pour la dictature
concrètement que comptez-vous faire
politiquement d'abord et qu'elle pouvait
vous faire vous défendre vos idées
nous nous prononcerons comme contre ce
référendum ce n'est qu'une phase mais on
ne donne pas de possibilité de nous
exprimer et d'influencer le peuple on
n'a pas le droit de faire des assemblées
des meetings on ne peut pas écrire dans
les journaux on pépin s'est présenté à
la radio on peut pas utiliser et la
télévision prenez vous des risques à
nous répondre
vous savez je prends des risques de
nouveaux cas ce sont des risques de la
profession
j'ai déjà d'extraits une certaine
expérience
j'ai eu à 1976 7 - deux départements
dans une petite île dans la mer j'ai
volé un dos et à 1970 j'ai été condamné
par une cour martiale extraordinaire à
quatre ans et demi de prison à une
amende à peu près 8000 et 9000 $ beau
parce que dans une interview accordée au
journal de temp et nov j'ai préconisé la
formation d'un gouvernement d'unité
nationale
le silverado boulot s'est engagé à ce
que les élections parlementaires une
forme du nord se déroule avant la fin
d'année 74,7 promettre par l'importante
ou vides de sens mais c'est de la blague
ce sera un autre pacte 17 fax de la
soi-disant démocratisation de la
dictature
vous savez afin vous connaissez le papa
doc love désir désir caché sa dictature
sous les bonnets de magna
[Musique]